[Musik]
beben in der katholischen kirche
kardinal marx bietet dem papst seinen
rücktritt an
die kirche sei an einem toten punkt
angekommen
höhere benzinpreise für den klimaschutz
die finanziellen folgen des co2 preise
werden zum wahlkampfthema und 14.000
fans in der allianz arena die dfb-elf
kam bei der fußball-em ihre heimpartien
in münchen vor zuschauern spielen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem freitag polizei ist auch dabei
für den sport hallo schön und ein
paukenschlag in der katholischen kirche
aus enttäuschung über die schleppende
aufklärung der missbrauchsfälle zieht
kardinal marx radikale persönliche
konsequenzen
der 67 jährige hat den papst angeboten
auf sein amt als bischof von freising
und münchen zu verzichten
marx gehört zu den einflussreichsten
katholischen würdenträgern sechs jahre
war er vorsitzender der deutschen
bischofskonferenz hat immer wieder
gesellschaftliche und politische
debatten mitgeprägt er drängte auch auf
reformen seiner kirche initiierte den
sogenannten synodalen weg nur das könne
ein wendepunkt sein
stefan leifert sollte jetzt kommen aber
auch mal mit heißer handgestrickt ich
hab noch ich habe noch kurz hoffnung
dass er kommt dieser beitrag aus münchen
der uns die hintergründe zu diesem
überraschenden rücktrittsangebot jetzt
kommt es aus seinem münchner amtssitz
machte kardinal marx heute öffentlich
worum er den papst vor zwei wochen
gebeten hat aus dem amt entlassen zu
werden wir sind schrieb er papst
franziskus an einem gewissen toten punkt
der aber auch zu einem wendepunkt werden
könne
in einer krise auch verursacht durch
eigenes versagen heute erklärte kardinal
marx sich vor der presse der münchner
kardinal marx gehört zum engsten
beraterkreis von papst franziskus als
vorsitzender der deutschen bischöfe ließ
er den sexuellen kindesmissbrauch in der
katholischen kirche wissenschaftlich
untersuchen
und setzt sich seither für reformen ein
der meinungsfreudige mahner trat im
vergangenen jahr als vorsitzender der
deutschen bischofskonferenz zurück
amtsmüde ist er nicht möchte mit seinem
rückzug aus dem bischofsamt vielmehr ein
zeichen setzen
der richtige seinen rücktritt angeboten
hat weil er ist ja eine derjenigen der
die kraft und auch die intellektuelle
kraft hat veränderungen in der
katholischen kirche voranzutreiben
andere er nicht und ich glaube der
katholischen kirche wird ein
herausgehobener stelle eine wichtige
person jetzt fehlen
der vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz georg bätzing äußerte
verständnis für den ungewöhnlichen
schritt seines vorgängers und bedauerte
marx amtsverzicht gleichzeitig in jedem
fall ist der schritt des münchner
kardinals ein klares bekenntnis für eine
reform der katholischen kirche und jetzt
ist unser fachmann aus der kirchen
redaktion bei mir jürgen erbacher guten
abend irgend geht da der falsche wie es
die katholischen laien sagen kardinal
marx steht wie sie beitrag angeklungen
ist für reformen und von daher würden es
sehr viele gläubige bedauern wenn der
papst diesen rücktritt annehmen würde
marx hat mit diesem schritt sicher den
druck auf alle verantwortungsträger in
der katholischen kirche erhöht zum einen
darüber nachzudenken wer muss moralische
verantwortung übernehmen und wie steht's
um die notwendigen reformen und ich
denke auch wenn er heute es
zurückgewiesen hat der blick geht
natürlich dann auch nach köln wo
kardinal marx extrem unter druck steht
und sagt ein rechtsgutachten weist mir
nichts nach ich muss nicht an rücktritt
denken und bei den reformen ist er auch
oft bei denen die dagegen sind was
bedeutet dieser schritt von marx für die
weltkirche kann das tatsächlich ein
signal zum aufbruch werden
also was hier heute in deutschland
passiert ist wurde weltweit innerhalb
der katholischen kirche genau beobachtet
und wahrgenommen
kardinal marx ist einer der
einflussreichsten kardinäle in der
weltkirche ein enger berater von papst
franziskus er hat auch den papst oft
angetrieben und hat gesagt du musst beim
missbrauch konsequent handeln du musst
reformen angehen von daher ist bei
dieser entscheidung glaube ich auch ein
bisschen die frage nach dem künftigen
kurs auch von papa von papst franziskus
ob er jetzt kardinal marx
hält oder ob er ihn gehen lässt die
spannung bleibt dankeschön jürgen
erbacher für den moment und direkt nach
uns gibt's auch ein zdf spezial zum
rücktrittsgesuch von kardinal marx
wie viel sind wir bereit für den
klimaschutz zu zahlen seit tagen sorgt
der vorschlag der grünen für zündstoff
die benzinpreise schneller zu erhöhen
das sei unsozial und treffe vor allem
die ärmeren heißt es auch von spd und
union
dabei hat die große koalition die
entsprechenden instrumente selbst
eingeführt die co2 preise gegen die
klimakrise machen eben auch benzin
teurer
andreas ruppert die spritpreise
sie klettern und klettern grund neben
der wieder gestiegenen weltweiten
rohölnachfrage die seit jahresbeginn
geltende co2 steuern auf kraftstoffe mit
der die bundesregierung die klimakrise
in den griff kriegen will
durch die jährliche erhöhung der co2
preisen bis 2025 wird auch der co2 preis
anteil bei den kraftstoffen in der
zukunft steigen das ziel ist es die
attraktivität von alternativen zu
erhöhen und einen sparsameren
verbrauchen damit weniger co2 zu
bewirken
deshalb steht im klimaschutzgesetz das
ab dem 11 20 21 der preis pro tonne co2
von 25 auf 55 euro im jahr 20 25
ansteigen soll
für den benzinpreis bedeutet das dann
circa 16 cent mehr pro liter
die grünen allen voran kanzlerkandidat
ihn annalena baerbock haben die hitzige
benzinpreis debatte ausgelöst mit der
forderung im entwurf für das
wahlprogramm dem preis für eine tonne
co2 auf 60 euro zu erhöhen und das
bereits ab 20 23 für den benzinpreis
bedeutet dass nochmals einen aufschlag
von 10 cent so die grünen
in unseren augen geht es beim co2 preis
nicht darum das geld einzunehmen sondern
wir wollen es zurück geben und zwar zu
100 prozent in dem sich die leute dann
kostengünstige autos kaufen können oder
eine energie die elbe kommen sozial
gerecht das will auch die linke statt
über benzinpreise zu streiten gebe seien
viel
einfacheres mittel wir brauchen einen
preiswerten und vor allen dingen
zuverlässigen öffentlichen
personennahverkehr der wirklich jeden
ort in unserer republik erreicht
klimaschutz und wahlkampf die debatte
über die co2 steuer und die spritpreise
wird wohl noch eine ganze weile andauern
er fragte nach in berlin bei chuck und
sarah banerjee was zeigt uns diese
debatte ja vor allem zwei dinge nämlich
zum einen dass das klima thema wenig
taugt für den ganz klassischen groben
schwarz-weiß schlagabtausch den man oft
im wahlkampf mitbekommt und zum anderen
wie sehr der druck tatsächlich jetzt
steigt konkret zu werden
wer sich den klimazielen verpflichtet
fühlt und das sind im bundestag momentan
alle parteien mit ausnahme der afd
da wird sich immer häufiger erklären
müssen und sagen müssen was denn die
eigenen vorschlage sind wo sollen
einschnitte erfolgen welche kosten
werden dadurch verursacht und wer soll
diese kosten am ende tragen damit sind
sicherlich auch unangenehme nachrichten
verbunden an die betraut sich dann so
keiner wirklich ran wenn es darum geht
stimmen zu gewinnen im wahlkampf und das
führt aber dazu dass der druck noch mehr
steigt wir haben heute von 8
umweltverbänden eine forderung gehört
die haben einen brandbrief geschrieben
in dem sie sagen diese unredliche
schlagabtausch dieser unredliche
wahlkampf solle bitte aufhören und man
sollte sich doch mal konkret darauf
verständigen was die besten maßnahmen
sind beim klimaschutz also das wird ein
schwieriges und sehr komplexes thema für
die parteien im wahlkampf
danke nach berlin chuck unternahm sie
gilt als stimmungstest für die
bundestagswahl im september die
landtagswahl am sonntag in sachsen
anhalt laut aktuellen politbarometer
liegt die cdu vorn mit 30 prozent
zweitstärkste kraft wäre die afg mit 23
prozent gefolgt von der linken 11,5 spd
10 grünen und fdp 6,5 prozent als
ministerpräsidenten wollen 68 prozent
reiner haseloff von der cdu behalten
37 prozent der befragten wissen aber
noch gar nicht ob und wen sie wählen und
so wird bis zum schluss gekämpft andreas
weise er ist das zugpferd der cdu in
sachsen
anhalts ministerpräsident reiner
haseloff die partei setzt im wahlkampf
voll auf ihn mit plakaten und digital
dass der reale kontakt zum wähler
mangelware war stört haseloff kaum auf
der anderen seite war das durchaus seine
qualität des dialogs der sich daraus
entwickelte der manchmal besser war als
mit stören versehen markt
veranstaltungen oder auf welchen plätzen
dann an die entsprechenden wählerinnen
und wähler hinzu kommen trotz corona die
afg setzt von anfang an auf die
marktplätze egal wie stark die größte
oppositionspartei im landtag am sonntag
wird das sie wohl nicht mitregieren
werden ist ihnen schon jetzt klar man
kann auch so politik machen wenn man das
nicht anders schafft ja aber das wollen
die leute ihn nicht die leute wollen
hier mal verantwortung von zwei
konservativen kräften
inwiefern das hier link versehen die
linke setzt im endspurt auf
bundesprominenz und hofft deutlich
besser abzuschneiden als es die umfragen
jetzt hergeben also ich gehe mit einem
guten gefühl in den wahlabend weil wir
tatsächlich alles versucht haben
herauszuholen was wir bei der
bundespolitisch gut aufgestellt sind
weil wir inhaltlich die richtigen themen
haben die für sachsen anhalts stehen wo
es besser gehen kann wo es besser gehen
muss trotz seines historischen absturz
des vor fünf jahren regierte die spd
dann weiter in der sogenannten kenia
koalition mit pläne für die kommende
legislaturperiode investitionen nach der
krise auch in unsere gesundheitssysteme
ins krankenhaus mit einem gesetz das für
gute löhne sorgt so wie wir es mit dem
tariftreuegesetz vorhaben und das thema
schule und bildung das prinzip sehr
vielen menschen auf den nägeln
die dritte kenia partei die
bündnisgrünen setzen voll auf
klimaschutz wir kämpfen dafür
drittstärkste kraft zu werden ich glaube
das ist möglich in diesem land wo sich
immer mehr menschen für klimaschutz
interessieren und es ist auch wichtig
weil dass es die große zukunftsaufgabe
und das muss ein stärkeres gewicht in
der nächsten landesregierung haben laut
letzte umfragen könnte es auch die fdp
ins landesparlament schaffen und so für
mehr koalitionsfragen spiele in
sachsen-anhalt sorgen
super nanny nach dem mutmaßlichen
abrechnungsbetrug in schnell testzentren
in nordrhein westfalen hat es zwei
festnahmen gegeben
das hat die ermittelnde bochumer
staatsanwaltschaft bestätigt den
betreibern wird vorgeworfen mehr corona
tests abgerechnet als durchgeführt zu
haben
jetzt der blick auf die virus zahlen in
deutschland laut robert-koch-institut
haben sich 3165 menschen neu angesteckt
das sind 4215 weniger als vergangenen
freitag 86 weitere todesfälle kamen
innerhalb von 24 stunden dazu die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents ist
aufgrund 30 gesunken
in immer mehr bundesländern gibt es
weitere lockerungen in berlin und
hamburg davon heute an die innen
gastronomie wieder aufmachen
ab montag gilt das auch in bayern dort
werden außerdem die kontakt
beschränkungen deutlich entschärft mehr
ist wieder wirklich auch an der küste in
mecklenburg vorpommern können ab heute
wieder touristen aus ganz deutschland
urlaub machen
voraussetzung ein aktueller negative
corona test auch auslandsreisen werden
leichter ab sonntag sind unter anderem
italien tschechien und weite teile
österreichs keine coroner risikogebiete
mehr heißt wer von dort auf dem landweg
zurückkehrt braucht keinen test und
keine quarantäne mehr
heute vor genau 32 jahren ließ die
chinesische führung die
demokratiebewegung in ihrem land blutig
niederschlagen
wochenlang hatten hunderttausende auf
dem tiananmen platz in peking
demonstriert dann ließ die regierung in
der nacht zum vierten juni 1989 den
platz räumen
hunderte womöglich mehr als 1000
menschen wurden getötet
doch das massaker wird in china
totgeschwiegen jedes öffentliche
gedenken wird verhindert stefanie schöne
bauen
diese kerzen sind gefährlich denn sie
haben symbolkraft sollen erinnern an die
geschichte des massakers vom tiananmen
chinas machthaber wollen das nicht erst
recht nicht in hongkong
hunderte polizisten vernichten kerzen
als seines staates
in einem totalitären system ist freiheit
ein rares gut
ein meer von kerzen in hongkong gibt den
menschen hoffnung weiter zu kämpfen
das ist der grund warum die chinesische
regierung so viel angst vor menschen hat
die die hoffnung auf freiheit nicht
aufgeben
vor 32 jahren kämpften die studenten
diese bilder des massakers auf dem
tiananmen will china aus dem gedächtnis
der geschichte verbannen
damals starben mehrere tausend menschen
in ganz china
genaue zahlen gibt es bis heute nicht
der victoria park in hongkong war 30
jahre lang das symbol der freiheit denn
hier durfte der opfer mit einem
kerzenmeer gedacht werden
heute ist der viktoriapark hermetisch
abgeriegelt hongkongs freiheit ist
längst verloren
es drohen bis zu fünf jahre haft für
jeden der gedenkt in der gruppe mit
kerzen
einige wurden jetzt schon festgenommen
wegen unrechtmäßiger versammlungen
da kann ich doch nicht einfach
wegbleiben das wichtigste ist ich werde
unterstützen wo ich kann
hongkongs menschen erinnern kreativ und
ungebrochen an das massaker schwarze
kleidung und ein licht so werden sie
selbst zum symbol einer freiheit die es
nicht mehr gibt
die usa setzten weitere chinesische
unternehmen auf eine sanktionsliste den
firmen wird vorgeworfen an
überwachungstechnologie beteiligt zu
sein
die unterdrückung oder schwerwiegende
menschenrechtsverletzungen erleichtern
us investoren dürfen künftig nicht mehr
in diese unternehmen investieren
das gab es auch noch heute eine stunde
lang alle sechsbeiner registrieren die
durch wald wiesen oder park krabbeln ab
heute ruft der naturschutzbund wieder
zur insekten zählung auf besonders
gefragt der marienkäfer aber auch bienen
schmetterlinge und andere sollen den
narben online gemeldet werden seit
jahren geht der insekten bestand bei uns
zurück unter anderem wegen intensiver
landwirtschaft und immer
der versiegelte flächen wirst du auch
insekten zählen ja total
aber wir kommen zum kollektiven juhu das
heute von einer nacht aus münchen aus
genauso wirklich gutem grund bei den
vier em spielen in münchen dürfen nun
doch jeweils 14.000 fans ins stadion
bayerns landesregierung hat dafür grünes
licht gegeben im tiroler trainingslager
sorgte die nachricht für große freude
darauf mussten fans lange warten nun
können sie bald wieder die
nationalspieler im stadion erleben alle
im team freuen sich auf die
unterstützung der zuschauer
das ist einfach gigantisch dass nach so
langer zeit endlich mal wieder ein paar
fans sind ins stadion rein dürfen auch
wenn sie jetzt noch 14.000 sind glaubt
das wird sich anhören wie 80.000 und
deswegen sind wir alle sehr froh darüber
dass der eine oder andere dann ins
stadion darf also rund um eine geile
geschichte würde ich sagen
bis zum frankreich spiel in münchen
wollen alle fit sein sollte allerdings
konnten mats hummels und lukas
klostermann wegen knieproblemen nur ein
individuelles programm bestreiten beide
sollen aber morgen wieder am
teamtraining teilnehmen
ja und die u21-nationalmannschaft hat
ist dem art eben schon vorgemacht nach
dem 2 2 1 halbfinalsieg gegen die
niederlande greift die auswahl am
sonntag gegen portugal nach dem em titel
zumindest die begeisterung im deutschen
team kann man durchaus schon als
titelverdächtig beschreiben gegen die
niederlande gibt der leverkusener
florian würz gleich nach 29 sekunden die
richtung vor der er mit seinen treffern
zum 1 und nur sieben minuten später zum
2 0 spielerischen nachdruck verleiht
ein niederländisches gegentor kann am
verdienten deutschen erfolg nichts
weiter ändern
wir machen das ab morgen gedanken über
portugal heute abend genießen ein ganz
tolles halbfinale was wir gewonnen
übermorgen nun also das finale in dem
sich das deutsche team im können und in
der begeisterung mit den portugiesen auf
augenhöhe begegnen wird
alexander zverev steht im achtelfinale
der french open in paris
deutschlands bester tennisspieler
gewinnt im stade roland garros gegen den
serben laszlo die ehre mit 6 2 7 5 und 6
nach zwei stunden und acht minuten
verwandelt wäre auf den ersten matchball
und erreicht damit als erster deutscher
die runde der letzten 16
zweiter tag bei dem finale den deutschen
meisterschaften in 18 sportarten für
einen glanzpunkt sorgt die
schwimmerinnen anna elend in berlin
die frankfurterin verbesserte in zwölf
jahre alten deutschen rekord über 100
meter brust mit einer minute und
sechseinhalb sekunden ist sie eine halbe
sekunde schneller als sarah poewe bei
der wm in rom 2009 elend gewinnt den
titel vor julia tietz in münchen und
bente fischer neckarsulm rekord
europameister patrick hausding verpasst
beim synchronspringen mit partner lars
rüdiger beinahe die olympia-teilnahme
der halt geht verloren bei dreieinhalb
auerbachsalto nur platz drei für die
favoriten die gesamtpunktzahl reicht am
ende dennoch für olympia und ganz frisch
das noch lemgo ist pokalsieger im
handball gratulieren wir auf jeden fall
die schüler hier zahlt auch heute wieder
zu unwettern geführt auf der
schwäbischen alb in bühlenhausen
entluden sich kräftige gewitter mit
starkregen und hagel zum manchmal hat es
kalt erwischt da halt nur noch die kluft
unter fach und diese mischung aus schule
blitz und donner bleibt uns erhalten wo
und wo nicht erzählt gleich katja
honnefer um 10.18 freut sich marietta
slomka ob sie im heute schon mal und wir
freuen uns wenn sie morgen wieder dabei
sind hier übernehmen die kollegen vom
zdf spezial und wir sagen tschüss
wünschen ihnen ein unbeschwertes
wochenende machen sie es gut
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren zwischen
dem hoch bei moskau und dem tief bei
madrid kommt schwül-heiße luft zu uns
und sie bringt kräftige gewitter mit die
allerhöchsten wolken haben wir für sie
mal rot eingefärbt da sehen sie sehr
schön wie die gewitter in die höhe
schießen
bei uns in mitteleuropa bei uns in
deutschland ging es etwa um 11 uhr los
heute vormittag dann entwickelte es sich
es brodelt in der atmosphäre es gab
kräftige gewitter mit hagel platzregen
und sturmböen und mit solchen gewittern
haben das auch in der nacht zu tun
die temperaturen sinken auf 17 bis 11
grad und morgen erwarten uns wieder die
höchsttemperaturen an der elbe dort
werden bis zu 28 grad erreicht deutlich
freundlicher ist es an der ostsee mit 19
bis 20 grad dort strahlt die sonne der
ostwind hält auch morgen hier noch die
gewitter auf distanz zwischen der schlei
und der uckermark die gewitter werden
wieder heftig ausfallen schwerpunkt
morgen sachsen anhalt sachsen und
thüringen
auch in süddeutschland gibt es gewitter
nur himmel südwesten da sind es nur noch
regenschauer
dort ist es schon ein bisschen kühler
bei 22 bis 25 grad an der donau werden
dagegen noch einmal 26 grad erreicht
auch am sonntag gibt es noch
unwetterartige gewitter besonders im
osten danach wird es langsam ruhiger
schönen abend noch